question maufroy si je te pose des
questions à doit de répondre qu'est ce
que te répondent les arbres quand tu
leur parles rien ce genre de la feuille
rien et sans dur de la feuille
le programme fort de ta campagne de la
nuance chose si j'avais compris je suis
réaliste et les connards
si j'avais compris je saurais te
l'expliquer connard ça c'est ma vie ta
participe à l'émission 60 jours 60 nuits
et nice people tels mais faire quoi
comme autre émission danse avec les
marseillais dans l'îlot de la tentation
de ta mère j'avance avec les marseillais
dans l'île de la tentation de ta mère
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
francis n'a fait les plus grandes scènes
willan carrière immense ce que tu un
petit rituel avant de monter sur scène
oui oui je claque m'habite sur la scène
pour voir l'acoustique à dire ça alors
je claque ma bile sur la scène encore
l'acoustique de la salle et je claque
m'habite sur la scène pour avoir
l'acoustique de la salle
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors francis qui est l'homme politique
le plus sincère en ce moment sans
conteste patrick balkany basse et
patrick balkany
[Rires]
ces supplices ton truc de l'oreillette
il souffre prend 1,6 avec eux c'est quoi
le petit kyste personnel de francis
reynes quand il est chez lui
je retire ses bottes de merde je retire
ses modes de merde tu vois là encore
français bah oui oui à son tube et je
suis bien c'est bien que je suis tu sais
bien que j'ai pas de chez moi je sais
sur un motif monkey toi alors là motif
c2c de changer de chez moi tous les
jours genre hier soir tu as dormi hier
soir joie eric doigt dans le cul de
magloire les jours aucune place libre
alors
[Applaudissements]
allez merci laurent passer leur message